y las galápagos una maravilla natural
patrimonio de la humanidad desde 1978
situadas en el océano pacífico a mil
kilómetros del continente americano son
consideradas un museo marino hogar de un
sinnúmero de especies poseen una rica
vida silvestre y playas que impactan por
su belleza pero ese impacto ha cambiado
para muchos que las visitan pequeñas
partículas de micro plásticos casi
imperceptibles al ojo humano han llegado
al mar y la arena de las playas un grupo
de voluntarios junto a diplomáticos
europeos realizaron una jornada de
limpieza tarea laboriosa y complicada
obviamente no vienen de los galápagos
para mí es la demostración del flagelo
mundial de la contaminación por micro
plásticos
que originen de todas las partes del
mundo y que van a de manera muy masiva
que va a ocupar el resto del mundo los
pequeños enemigos que hacen un daño
gigante al ecosistema llegan incluso a
los hogares ya que entran a la cadena
alimenticia de la fauna marítima que
luego es ingerida por los humanos
ecuador hizo un llamado para que los
grandes contaminantes del mundo cambien
su forma de utilizar el plástico que
cada uno de sus países tiene que evitar
que este 80% de la basura que recogemos
aquí en galápagos no pertenece ni al
ecuador ni a las islas galápagos
pertenece a otros países del mundo como
los océanos se han convertido en
vertederos de basura a causa de las
actividades turísticas económicas
accidentes petroleros y la producción de
plástico según estimaciones de la onu
entre 8 y 13 millones de toneladas de
este material son descargadas en el mar
cada año esto equivale a la entrada de
un camión cargado de basura en el océano
cada minuto